all right I got a serious question for
$100,000 just suck a man's penis man's
penis yeah yeah you get to pick the dude
yeah so final dig approve oh all you of
course anything I want to you ever sick
except for mean Blake's Yeah right well
then yeah totally definitely okay uh-huh
hundred G's yeah I think so all right
okay what about 75,000 yo yeah yeah okay
sure let's do real five grand
yes realest yeah I'll be 30 seconds away
from getting a pretty sweet used
motorcycle no it would take you way
longer than $10 you are are you kidding
me right now you seen these lips I have
have you enjoyed the presence of me
eating a kabocha just read ankh wow it's
weird girls that goes alike I'm
impressed by that okay hold on what is
the absolute least amount of money you
could get paid to blow with that our
talking if I'm honest with myself yeah I
have to say $900 what was that okay
are you all right uh yeah yeah I think
so
hey did you see my call i said i said
900 I heard 900,000 dude I've got
standards I'm not just blowing everybody